here's a interesting article from CNN
says Christian leadership in the U.S has
typically been seen as a male occupation
the right for women to be ordained and
serve as Faith leaders has been hard won
over decades and in several major
factions like the Roman Catholic and
southern baptist churches women are
barred from the highest levels of
leadership however among mainstream
denominations that do ordain women a sea
change is occurring
more women are entering Seminary and
other theological programs with the
intent of becoming priests as it follows
more women are also occupying these
roles after being ordained experts say
one of the main reasons for the increase
is that Women of Faith are looking at
their religious traditions and sensing a
need for change
Alexis Abernathy the chief academic
officer had Fuller Theological Seminary
in Pasadena California says women and
men in the church have seen abuse and
suffering that seeing the role of the
patriarchy in the church they want to
address constructively some of these
challenges that have been facing both
the church and our society they're
saying enough of this we need to be
different so I think a lot of these
women are marshaling energy in that
direction
uh and so it's an article all about all
about this alleged change that's
happening where women are finally
assuming leadership positions in the
church uh in in churches all across
America
two quick points about that first it's a
myth that churches in America have been
run by men up to this point
so if more women are getting involved in
churches that's not a sea change at all
it's not any kind of change that's just
more of the same most churches have been
run by women for the past several
decades okay maybe not in an official
capacity or as pastors or priests in all
these cases but women have been running
the show in most churches for a long
time
anyone who's been going to church for
any period of time knows that I mean
even in the Catholic church where women
cannot become priests still your average
Catholic parish
uh not gonna have a female priest
but there will be in almost every case a
gaggle of women who basically run things
there might be a liberal nun in there
you know one of those nuns that wears
regular clothes doesn't wear the Habit
uh maybe there's like a female music
director or something other positions as
well but whatever the position
the women have in the church or maybe
they have none at all
there are also be a lot of women who
don't have an official position uh you
know they they are just part of the the
congregation and yet they have inserted
themselves into all these different
aspects of what goes on in the church
and they're very vocal and they're very
you know if there's anything that
happens that upsets them uh it's whoever
actually is supposed to be running the
church the pastor the priest knows it's
like okay I want to hear from them about
this
and they effectively run the church
um so and that is why
you know for years now
most churches have catered to women
because they've effectively been run by
women churches America are already
female-led okay much to their detriment
that's because the last thing that we
need here
is more women
in church leadership positions that's
the last thing we need
that the church is already too feminized
too soft too focused on feelings and
emotions and being welcoming and
inclusive
all of that is coming from Liberal women
in these churches or most of it anyway
they're the ones driving this
um the church
Christendom in America is what I you
know I'm talking about all all of
Christianity basically
with rare exception is far too soft and
feminine and again it's been that way
for years
uh so you it adding more women into
leadership it's just it's just going to
drive that problem even more which of
course is what CNN wants
so they realize that
and it's a self-perpetuating problem the
more feminine the church is the less men
want to go and the less that men want to
go the more women are in charge
because there's no one else there uh and
the more and the more they're in charge
the more feminine it gets and the less
men want to go
so the more women are in charge the more
feminine it gets the more what meant the
less men want to go and it's just on and
on and on that's self-perpetuating cycle
is it it's uh and it's really more of a
death spiral self-perpetuating death
spiral for the church
you know C.S Lewis and I'm going to
butcher the quote I don't remember the
exact quote but um
uh he talks about how going to church it
should have the feeling of
you know uh of getting battle plans of
like of of of uh you're in the middle of
a war and you're you're meeting
and you're going over your battle plans
for the for the battle ahead and as you
have very much of that that feeling of
like spiritual warfare and you're all
soldiers and you're you're meeting
together and you're discussing what your
battle strategy is going to be
that's that's the feeling that church
should have
um he put it much more eloquently than
that
but that's that's right that's that's
what church should feel like because
that's what it is
we're in the middle of a spiritual
warfare and that's what churches that in
churches it's supposed to equip us
for that spiritual warfare
and and one of the advantages that we're
supposed to have in going to church
every week is that it equips us for the
battle ahead for the next week
like we're coming off of the battlefield
and battered and bruised and from from
the past week of fighting it and now
we're collecting ourselves and we're and
we're uh we're getting ready to go back
out in into that that Battlefield again
but that's how it should feel
and if churches have that feeling then
you're going to have a lot more men
showing up because that's what men want
you know a company is looking out for
you when they actually upgrade your
service and they don't charge you for it
this is great news for new and current
Pure Talk customers pure talk just added
data to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but haven't made the switch
take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you'll get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is why I
love Pure Talk they're veteran owned
they only hire the best customer service
team located right here in the great USA
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com
slash walls Pure Talk Wireless for
Americans buy Americans Grand Canyon
University is an affordable private
Christian University located in
beautiful Phoenix Arizona praise for its
culture of community giving and impact
Grand Canyon University integrates the
free market system into their education
welcoming Christian worldview
perspectives into over 320 academic
programs with more than 260 of those
programs online Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life so why wait if you're
ready to take your education to the next
level find your purpose at Grand Canyon
University visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
but that's not what churches feel like
that's not that's not the uh to use the
as the kids would say that's not the
vibe okay that's not the vibe you get
for most churches
rare exception again and now I'm always
going to hear from people say oh my
shirt's not like that well then then God
bless you in your church
but most churches it is
it's it's it does not have the feeling
of like uh spiritual warfare battle
plans or go into war you're fighting
you're fighting the forces of evil that
is not the feeling and everything it's
it's all set up to not feel that way
everything from the way that the
churches are built now you know they're
built to look like uh either they look
like kind of these non-descript office
building types very sterile environments
um or they look you know if it's a mega
church they look like a just a concert
venue and you know an auditorium of some
kind uh but that's how they look and
then you go in and the music is very
feminine music and everything about it
the message from from uh the pastor a
very feminine message always about
welcoming and being nice and being
friends
and Men sit in there and they are bored
to death by it they are just bored to
tears
and feeling like they had nothing out of
it
and they leave and droves the women take
over more and it's again continues and
continues
um
so this CNN is not reporting on a on a
new development in churches but rather
just more the same unfortunately if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed